This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这是一档iHeart播客节目。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中的心理韧性、健身之道以及如何建立适应力。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《百分之二》。也就是数字“2”%。欢迎收听《回首过往》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people listen to look back at it on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts hey what's good y'all you're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host care games this space is about black men's experiences having honest conversations
与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。人们在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回首过往》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难求知》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话。
that's really not safe to have anywhere but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing how many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you not to be played with and just because you have the capabilities you have the capabilities that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不太安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且仅仅因为你有能力，你拥有这些能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《艰难求知》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranchini.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·兰奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这就是《陷入爱网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《陷入爱网》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型。以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we dive into the psychology of our 20s. This episode today, we are going to get quite vulnerable. If you are a frequent listener of the show, you will know that I'm always looking for episode suggestions, things that you guys, my fellow 20-something-year-olds, are going through as inspiration for the podcast. Someone sent in this suggestion, actually multiple of you sent in this suggestion, and I read some of these messages and just thought, how have we never discussed this before? What we're talking about today is a fear of intimacy. So many of you have been waiting
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪一个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，让我们一起深入探讨二十多岁的心理学。今天这一期节目，我们将变得相当感性。如果你是节目的忠实听众，你就会知道我一直在寻找节目建议，寻找你们这些和我一样二十多岁的人正在经历的事情，以此作为播客的灵感。有人发来了这个建议，实际上不止你们中的一个人发来了这个建议，当我读到其中一些信息时，我只是在想，我们怎么从来没有讨论过这个？我们今天要谈论的是亲密恐惧症。你们中的许多人一直在等待
for this episode, and there is just a wealth of research, content, articles, theories that go along with it. And I also think it's something that so many, so many of us in our 20s struggle with in silence and might not even realize that we are going through. I think a fear of intimacy is so valuable to understand because it's also one of those ideas that has become misconstrued, misunderstood, overused in recent years. And with that overuse, sometimes we don't always know the facts and of course the science and the psychology behind why it occurs, how it presents in our lives and also ways to move forward, potential solutions. It's one of those classic catch-22 problems in psychology. We want more people to have a label for
这一期节目，并且与之相关的研究、内容、文章和理论可以说是非常丰富。而且我也认为，这是我们许多、许多二十多岁的人在沉默中苦苦挣扎，甚至可能都没有意识到自己正在经历的事情。我认为理解亲密恐惧症非常有价值，因为这也是近年被曲解、被误解、被过度使用的概念之一。随着这种过度使用，有时我们并不总是了解事实，当然还有它为什么会发生、它如何在我们的生活中表现出来的科学和心理学原理，以及前进的方法和潜在的解决方案。这是心理学中经典的进退两难的问题之一。我们希望更多的人为他们所经历的事情贴上标签，
what they're experiencing, but that label still needs to be an informed one and we want people to have the correct information about what they're describing. So that's what we're going to talk about today, because I think so many of us struggle with a fear of intimacy in our 20s, and I don't always think we have the right information. A fear of intimacy during this decade shows up in a lot of different, often invisible ways. Maybe you have found yourself in like a constant cycle of situationships. You push people away when they're trying to get to know you, both friends,
但这个标签仍然需要是一个基于充分了解的标签，我们希望人们对他们所描述的事物有正确的信息。所以这就是我们今天要讨论的内容，因为我认为我们二十多岁的人中，有太多人都在与亲密恐惧症作斗争，而且我不认为我们总是拥有正确的信息。在这个十年里，亲密恐惧症以许多不同的、通常是无形的方式表现出来。也许你发现自己陷入了某种类似“暧昧关系”（situationships）的无休止循环中。当人们试图了解你时，你会把他们推开，无论是朋友，
and people you're dating. You can never bring yourself to go on first dates. You start fights when things begin to feel safe. You may have placed all of these conditions on yourself for when you'll be allowed to date. You know, I can't date until I've lost weight, until I fix something about myself, until I love myself more. All of these actions and habits is a fear of vulnerability. And it is secretly keeping us from being vulnerable, intimate, with people.
还是你正在约会的人。你永远无法说服自己去进行第一次约会。当事情开始变得安全时，你反而会挑起争端。你可能为自己设定了所有这些允许自己约会的条件。你知道的，我不能约会，直到我减肥成功，直到我修复了自己身上的某个问题，直到我更爱自己。所有这些行为和习惯的背后，都是对脆弱感的恐惧。它在暗中阻止我们去和周围的人建立脆弱的、
around us because we are scared that when we get too close, we get hurt or that perhaps we aren't worthy of the love we think we deserve, so we shy away from any opportunity for us to be proven wrong. I think to be emotionally intimate with someone is to essentially give ourselves and give other people the guidebook on how exactly to hurt us. If you have been left, you know, scarred or burned by a past relationship, attachment problems in childhood, even if you're just feeling particularly insecure, I think that love can be one of the hardest things that we can put ourselves through because there are so much opportunity for disaster, so much opportunity to be hurt, so much so that we avoid that crucial source, that being love, and meaningful connection.
亲密的关系。因为我们害怕当我们靠得太近时会受到伤害，或者也许我们觉得自己不配得到我们认为自己应得的爱，所以我们避开任何可能证明我们是错的机会。我认为与某人保持情感上的亲密，本质上就是把我们自己以及给其他人一本关于如何确切伤害我们的指南。如果你被过去的恋爱关系留下了伤痕或灼伤，童年时期的依恋问题，或者即使你只是感到特别没有安全感，我认为爱可以说是我们能经历的最艰难的事情之一，因为这里有太多的灾难机会，太多的受伤机会，以至于我们避开了那个至关重要的源泉，也就是爱和有意义的连接。
It's actually quite devastating, really. I think a lot of us know this is going on behind the scenes. We are not blind to how this pattern of behavior and fear is active in our lives. We want to be open. We want a witness to our lives. We want to be seen. But it also comes with the realization that allowing ourselves to go through this might actually do something to hurt us further. Sometimes that fear is too strong to push past. So my hope is that this episode is of some help to you because I don't think big problems like this are overcome in a day, but the first step is actually being able to diagnose and understand the problem and having enough background information to proceed. So without further ado, let's get into it. So fear of
这其实挺让人心碎的，真的。我想我们很多人都知道幕后正在发生这一切。我们并不是对这种行为模式和恐惧在我们的生活中如何活跃视而不见。我们希望保持开放。我们希望有人见证我们的生活。我们希望能被看见。但这也伴随着一种意识到：让自己经历这一切可能会真正做些事情来进一步伤害我们。有时这种恐惧太强烈，无法克服。所以我希望这一期节目能对你们有所帮助，因为我不认为像这样的大问题能在一天内克服，但第一步实际上是能够诊断和理解问题，并拥有足够的背景信息来继续前进。所以废话不多说，让我们切入正题。亲密
intimacy is known by a few other names, the most common one being avoidance anxiety, which is sometimes applied to a lot more than just love. Avoidance anxiety really gets to. the heart of how a fear of intimacy is sustained. When we have an excessive fear, concern, worry towards a particular object or subject, the easiest way to actually regulate that anxious response is to kind of avoid anything that triggers it. So in that way, avoidance becomes a coping mechanism whereby we are so paralyzed by what would happen if we encountered our fear that we act in the most rational way we can. which is just to avoid that from ever happening.
恐惧症有几个其他的名字，最常见的是回避型焦虑（avoidance anxiety），有时它不仅适用于爱情，还适用于更多方面。回避型焦虑真正触及了亲密恐惧症是如何维持的核心。当我们对某个特定的对象或主体产生过度的恐惧、担忧、忧虑时，实际调节这种焦虑反应最简单的方法就是避开任何触发它的事物。通过这种方式，回避变成了一种应对机制，以至于我们对遇到恐惧时会发生的事情感到如此瘫痪，以至于我们采取了我们所能做出的最理智的行为。那就是干脆避免这种事情的发生。
In the case of a fear of intimacy, the trigger is not an object, though. It's not some fear like snakes or spiders or planes. It's the feeling or a situation that being in an intimate social contact with someone else might jeopardize our sense of security and safety that we have created for ourselves internally. Now, a fear of intimacy is actually quite multidis. It can be emotional, sexual, even intellectual or spiritual. So if we fear emotional intimacy, what we're fearing is sharing our innermost feelings
不过，在亲密恐惧症的情况下，触发因素不是一个物体。它不是像蛇、蜘蛛或飞机那样的某种恐惧。而是一种感觉或一种情况，即与他人保持亲密的社交接触可能会危及我们在内部为自己创造的安全感和稳妥感。现在，亲密恐惧症其实是一个多面体。它可能是情感上的、性方面的，甚至是理智或精神上的。因此，如果我们害怕情感上的亲密，我们所恐惧的是与某人分享我们内心深处的感受和真实情感，并可能把他们吓跑。也许是因为我们习惯了我们的感受不被重视或不被尊重，或者我们害怕他们会利用这些信息对我们做些什么。性亲密恐惧，
and true emotions with someone and perhaps scaring them off. Maybe because we are not accustomed to our feelings being important or respected, or we're scared of what they will be able to do to us with that information. A fear of sexual intimacy, it's also known as genophobia, is where we have this very serious anxiety about sharing that part of ourselves with someone else. Maybe we are worried about being hurt. We are reflecting on really hard and traumatic past experiences where we weren't given the respect that we deserve. And so now we see any time that we're having sex or any opportunity to be intimate with someone as possibly creating the same outcome. And that's an outcome that we want
也被称为性恐惧症（genophobia），是指我们对与其他人分享自己这部分经历感到非常严重的焦虑。也许我们担心受到伤害。我们在反思那些让我们没有得到应得尊重的艰难且创伤性的过去经历。所以现在我们将任何发生性行为的时刻或与某人亲密的机会都视为可能会产生相同的结果。而这是一个我们想要避免的结果。我们也有对理智亲密（intellectual intimacy）的恐惧。这并非其中的一个方面。我想我们很多人通常认为，理智亲密是对宏大思想、想法和核心信念的交流。这其实是我们内心深处非常脆弱、柔软、深沉的一部分，我认为在我们的生活中，很少有人真正能够接触到。他们可以利用这些信息做很多事情。我们可能会担心别人会不屑一顾或利用这些事情来对付我们。我们可能会担心他们不同意我们的观点。他们会让我们难堪，我们会意识到我们其实并没有想象中那么契合。所有这些恐惧的根源都是非常主观的，无论你害怕的是情感亲密、理智亲密还是性亲密。
to avoid. We also have that fear of intellectual intimacy. And that's not a facet of this. That's I think a lot of us typically think of, intellectual intimacy is this exchange of big ideas and thoughts and core beliefs. That is actually such a vulnerable, squishy, deep down part of ourselves that very few people, I think, ever really get access to in our lives. And there's a lot that they can do with that information. We might worry that someone will be dismissive or use these things against us. We might worry that they won't agree with us. They'll embarrass us, that we'll realize that we're actually not as connected as we thought. The root of all these fears is very subjective, whether you have a fear of emotional intimacy, intellectual intimacy, sexual intimacy.
它主要基于过去的经历以及一系列可以影响我们对待爱和接受爱的方式的历史。当我们有这种亲密恐惧症时，它会阻止我们参与那些能够建立终身或持久纽带的行为。不幸的是，你知道的，被爱就是去进行理智上的亲密，去进行情感上的亲密，有时还要进行性方面的亲密。可悲的是，一段关系确实有一些核心参数和必要的基础。如果我们真的想觉得自己应该接受或觉得我们能够接受爱进入我们的生活，我们就必须跨越这种分享我们内心深处部分的恐惧。我们之前简要提到了一些亲密恐惧症的表现，但为了更深入地探讨，你可能正在与此作斗争的一些迹象，无论你是否有意识地意识到，包括一系列非常短暂的恋情，它们都因为微不足道的事情而结束。他们给了你一点微小的反感（ick）。他们在约会时没有吃完所有的食物。他们不喜欢和你相同的音乐。这些反感，这些你认为合理的理由，实际上可能正在保护你免受一个更深层的解释，一个更深层的解释是：你觉得还没准备好。你正越来越接近走出舒适区边缘的临界点，所以你在寻找
It's based primarily on past experiences and a history with a whole bunch of things that can influence our approach to being loved and accepting love. when we have this fear of intimacy, it prevents us from engaging in behaviors that will create a lifelong or sustaining bond. Unfortunately for us, you know, to be loved is to be intellectually intimate, is to be emotionally intimate, is to sometimes be sexually intimate. And sadly, a relationship does have some core parameters and necessary foundations. And we will have to kind of get past this fear of sharing those deep parts of ourselves, if we ever want to truly feel like we should accept or feel like we can accept love into our lives. We mentioned some of the indicators of a fear of
你认为合理的理由来结束这段关系，而这与你无关，也不需要你真正去审视你对这段关系逐渐消亡所做出的贡献。这可能也与某种程度的关系强迫症（relationship OCD）或完美主义有关。关系强迫症是我非常非常着迷的一个概念，因为我确实认为有时它是我破坏恋爱关系的其中一个原因。这种形式的强迫症意味着，当涉及到浪漫伴侣时，我们对自己的担忧和疑虑有很多强迫性的想法，这些想法很难控制，感觉非常超出我们的控制，我们最终往往会针对我们和伴侣不合的微小迹象陷入这种过度警惕的状态。
intimacy briefly before, but to dive into it a little bit further, some of the signs that you might be struggling with this, whether consciously or not, includes a series of really short relationships that all end because of insignificant things. They gave you a small ick. They didn't finish all their food on a date. They didn't like the same music as you. These icks, these reasons that you think are valid, may actually be protecting you from a deep explanation, a deeper explanation, which is that you don't feel ready. You're getting too close to the edge of tipping out of your comfort zone, so you are searching
我们在寻找这段关系行不通的理由，以免他们给我们带来突如其来的打击。我们在受到伤害之前寻找与他们分手的理由。甚至在约会的早期阶段，我们可能会对潜在的伴侣抱有非常高的标准，甚至可能是无法达到的标准，因为我们仍然觉得自己表现得很开放。我们仍然在说，是的，我准备好谈恋爱了，但我只是不想将就。我的标准太高了，我就是不想要任何低于这个标准的人。这就是我们对自己说的话，而实际上根本没有人能达到我们的期望。有时我们的标准实际上是相互矛盾的，但这为我们提供了将人们拒之门外的机会。
for what you see as a valid reason to end the relationship that has nothing to do with you and won't require you to actually look at your contribution to this relationship fizzling out. This may also be linked to a level of relationship OCD or perfectionism. Relationship OCD is something that I am really, really fascinated about because I do think that at times it's been one of the reasons I've sabotaged relationships. What this form of OCD means is that we have a lot of obsessive thoughts about our concerns and doubts when it comes to a romantic partner that are really difficult to manage, that feel very much out of our control, we often end up existing in this state of hypervigilance towards very small
这并不是说你不值得去挑剔，你也不值得拥有最卓越、最惊艳的爱，但当我们开始看到我们对某人的需求中出现矛盾时，这就很有意思了。这些矛盾是相当好的证据，证明我们为自己设定的标准更多是为了保护，而不是为了提供信息。它们试图阻止我们陷入某些事情，而不是试图让我们对某些事情保持开放。对我来说，这总是导致一种“邻家的草更绿”（grass is greener）的心态。你不断地思考你的关系本该是多么完美。如果你缺少了一样东西，那就是失败。
signs that us and our partner are not compatible. We are looking for reasons that this isn't going to work before they blindside us. We are looking for reasons to break up with them before we get hurt. Even in the early stages of dating, we may hold potential partners to a really high standard, perhaps even an impossible one because we still feel like we're being open. We're still saying like, yeah, I'm ready for a relationship, but I just don't want to settle. My standards are so high that I just don't want anyone who's below that. And that's what we tell ourselves when actually there really isn't anyone who could ever meet our expectation. Sometimes our standards actually are opposed to each other, but it gives us this opportunity to keep people at bay.
你对一段可能并不存在的完美关系有着各种幻想。但通过不断投资于这种错觉，你把所有其他对爱的可能性都挡在了门外。每当谈到这一点时，我总是会想到一个被称为“90-10法则”（90-10 rule）的概念。最近TikTok上有一个关于这个的视频超级火爆，我认为出于最好的原因，我们中的许多人都落入了90-10法则的陷阱。这个的前提是，你可以和某人在一起，这个人有90%是你想要的全部，是你梦想的一切，是你童年时期的自己对爱的全部期望。但有那么10%就是不太对劲。
Now, that's not to say that you don't deserve to be picky and you don't deserve the most exceptional, amazing form of love, but it's interesting when we start to see contradictions and the things that we want from someone. Those contradictions are pretty good evidence that the standards we're setting for ourselves are a lot more protective than they are kind of informative. They're trying to stop us from something rather than trying to keep us open to something. This always, for me, resulted in a grass as greener mentality. You're constantly thinking about how your relationship should be perfect. How if you're missing one thing, it's a failure.
而这些事情并不是决定性的交易破坏者（deal breakers），对吧？它们只是一些小事，比如，哦，他们没有按照我想要的时间准确洗碗。或者，哦，他们没有我那么随性。你却让这10%盖过了那90%，以至于你出去寻找一个能满足这10%的人，但后来他们却只占了你真正想要的10%。你为了区区小事，放弃了一些对你而言实际上好得不得了的东西。
You have these fantasies about a flawless relationship that probably doesn't exist. But by continuing to invest in the delusion, you keep all these other possibilities for love at bay. The thing I always think about when it comes to this is this concept known as the 90-10 roar. Now, there was a video about this that went super viral on TikTok recently, and I think for the best kinds of reasons, so many of us fall into the trap of the 90-10 rule. The premise of this is that you can be with someone who is like 90% everything that you wanted, everything that you ever dreamed of, everything that your childhood self wanted from love. But there is this 10% that just isn't quite right.
有时我会说，即使表面上看起来不像，这也是亲密恐惧症的一个迹象。以下是其他一些表明某人正在为此苦恼的事情。当你处于恋爱关系中时，你可能也会隐瞒信息或避免分享你的感受，因为这会让你变得过于脆弱。你还可能会通过情感试探（emotional bids）来测试你的伴侣。情感试探是指你试图通过以一种实际上是间接的方式获得伴侣的注意来与他们建立联系。
And those things aren't deal breakers, right? They're just small things like, oh, they don't do the dishes exactly when I want them to do them. Or, oh, they're not as like spontaneous as I am. and you let that 10% dominate over the 90% so that you go out looking for someone who fulfills the 10% but then they are only 10% of what you actually want. You've given up something that is actually incredibly good for you over small reasons.
我总是喜欢用挑起争端作为例子。并不是说你有什么好生气的。只是你感到没有安全感。你感到被困住了，你想要得到安抚。你想要以某种方式挑战你的关系，看看它能否度过这场争端，看看它能否挺过这场争风吃醋，看看那个人是否会留在你身边。再次强调，我认为这一切的根源都在于亲密恐惧症。现在，我们需要讨论这到底是从哪里来的。
Sometimes I would say that's a sign of a fear of intimacy even if it doesn't look like it on the surface. Here are some other things that would tell me that someone is struggling with this. When you are in a relationship, you may also withhold information or avoid sharing your feelings because it's going to make you too vulnerable. You also might test your partner through emotional bids. So emotional bids are these attempts to connect with your partner by gaining their attention in a way that is actually indirect.
有相当多的经历会产生这种行为模式或对爱情中亲密关系的这种反应。其中一些甚至似乎是相互对立的。所以它是非常主观的，取决于你自身的经历组合。不过，许多这样的担忧都出现在童年时期，但甚至像我们的青少年恋爱经历、过去的恋爱关系以及对吞噬感（engulfment）、不安全感的恐惧，也都在推波助澜。在我们深入探讨这一点之前，理解一个被称为“承诺准备度”（commitment readiness）的概念也很重要。所以承诺准备度是临床和研究心理学中一个相当新的测量指标，它本质上指的是我们对一段关系的开放程度和接受程度。我们每个人都有一定水平的承诺准备度，对我们建立亲密关系的能力有着某种
I always like to use the example of starting fights. It's not that you even have anything to be mad about. It's just that you are feeling insecure. you're feeling stuck and you want reassurance. You want to kind of challenge your relationship to see if it can push through this argument, see if it can push through this fight, whether that person is going to stay by your side. Once again, I think all of this has its roots in a fear of intimacy. Now, we need to talk about where exactly this comes from.
预先形成或预先决定的判断。如果你的承诺准备度较低，别人很难说服你在爱情或连接中迈出下一步，因为你觉得自己还没有准备好。而那些承诺准备度很高的人，这意味着他们是第一批跳入恋爱关系的人。他们已经准备好做出承诺。他们已经准备好接受那个标签。他们想要约会。他们想要谈恋爱。现在，亲密恐惧症反映了较低水平的承诺准备度。而这个因素、这个指标，受到以下因素的影响。所以，当谈到亲密恐惧症时，主要的理论是，所有这些所谓的“问题行为”都始于童年，通常是由于被忽视的、
There are quite a few experiences that create this pattern of behavior or this reaction to intimacy in love. Some of them actually seem to be in opposition with each other. So it is very subjective and based on your own mix of experiences. A lot of these concerns, though, emerge in childhood, but even things like our teenage relationships, past relationships, and a fear of engulfment, insecurity, they also contribute. Before we get into this, it's also important to understand this concept known as commitment readiness. So commitment readiness is a fairly new measure in clinical and research psychology, and it essentially refers to our openness and receptiveness to a relationship. Every single one of us has a level of commitment readiness, has this somewhat
混乱的、专断的育儿风格导致的。如果作为一个孩子，你没有从主要照顾者那里获得你所需的爱、关怀、安抚、同情、安全感，你可能就已经潜移默化地了解到，亲密关系并不是你可以依靠来满足需求的事物。你真的只能靠自己。所以你把那些可能试图靠近的人推开。这非常能够说明焦虑-回避型依恋风格（anxious avoidant attachment style）。这种情感。这种情感上的。你所经历的忽视，可能会导致你不自觉地去寻找那些镜像你过去经历的恋爱关系。因此，如果你在一个父母情感上不可用的环境中长大，这可能会无意中导致你在未来被情感上不可用的伴侣所吸引，
preformed or predetermined judgment of our ability to be in a relationship. If you have low commitment readiness, it's going to be difficult for you to, you know, for someone to convince you to take this next step in your love or in your connection because you just don't feel equipped. Whereas we have these people who have a high commitment readiness, that means that they are the first ones to jump into a relationship. They are ready for that commitment. They are ready for that label. They want to be dating. They want to be in a relationship. Now, a fear of intimacy, reflects a low level of commitment readiness. And that factor, that measure, is impacted by the following. So the major theory when it comes to a fear of intimacy is that all of these quote, unquote, problem behaviors began in childhood, normally as the result of a neglectful,
因为这只是在创造一种熟悉的模式。而且你可以把这些人保持在一个距离，当，你知道的，也许你其实才是那个情感上不可用的人时，你所做的是寻找那些能让你停留在熟悉、舒适和已知状态中的伴侣，那就是他们永远不会满足你的需求。他们永远不会成为那个问你今天过得怎么样、会突破你所设定的边界和各种障碍的人。所以你继续感到安全，而实际上你却在逃避更高水平的亲密感，因为那需要你放弃过去对爱的错误观念并变得脆弱。我想我们都对情感上不可用的照顾者会产生恐惧和回避的爱与连接模式有着某种基本理解。但在完全相反的方向上，也有一些新兴研究表明，在被过度保护、窒息般、专断的父母抚养长大，也会产生亲密恐惧症，因为我们担心我们的独立性。
disorganized overbearing parenting style. If as a child you did not receive the love, the care, the reassurance, the compassion, the security that you needed from your primary caregiver, you may have implicitly learned that close relationships are not something that you can rely on for your needs. You really only have yourself. So you push away people who might try and get close. That's very indicative of an anxious avoidant attachment style. This emotion. This emotional. neglect that you have experienced, it may cause you to unconsciously seek out relationships that mirror your past experience. So if you grew up in an environment with emotionally unavailable parents, this may unintentionally cause you to be drawn to emotionally unavailable partners in the
并且我们担心我们的自由，因为我们被教导说，亲密关系会迫使我们放弃自己的一部分，或者感到受到密切监视，感到受到密切观察。所以我几年前在澳大利亚某人的博士论文中偶然看到了这个理论，他们谈到过度的父母抚养实际上与不安全依恋风格有着真正的联系，特别是在年轻男性中。也许是因为
future because it's just creating a familiar pattern. And these people, you can also keep at a distance when, you know, maybe you are actually the emotionally unavailable one, what you're doing is seeking out partners who will allow you to stay in what is familiar, what is comfortable, and what you know, which is that they will never fulfill your needs. They will never be someone who is going to ask you how your day was, who's going to push past the boundaries and the kind of barriers that you've created. So you continue to feel safe when really you're actually avoiding a deeper level of intimacy that will require you to give up your past misconceptions of love and be vulnerable. I think we all have some basic understanding that emotionally unavailable
他们怨恨自己被密切观察的程度。他们不希望这种表现体现在他们的恋爱关系中。或者也许这是一种对他们在童年时期发现的不公的追溯性叛乱或抗议，表现为他们在成年后继续把想要靠近他们的人推开。无论那可能是什么，它显然因人而异，但它可能导致一些研究人员所说的“吞噬恐惧”（fear of engulfment），即我们害怕被控制、被支配、害怕在关系中迷失自我，然后在关系不可避免地结束时无法找到回家的路，因为我们有着爱不会持久的核心态度。
caregivers are going to create fearful and avoidant patterns of love and connection. But in the complete opposite direction, there's also been some emerging research that being raised by parents who were overprotective, smothering, overbearing, also creates a fear of intimacy because we fear for our independence. And we fear for our independence. And we fear for our our freedom because we have been taught that close relationships cause us to have to give up parts of ourselves or feel closely monitored, feel closely observed. So I came across this theory a couple of years ago in a PhD paper from someone in Australia and they talked about how overprotective parenting is actually really linked to an insecure attachment style, particularly in young men. Maybe it's
如果你是一个特别过度独立的人，一个拒绝寻求帮助的请求、更喜欢独处、在内心深处相信自己除了自己谁也不需要的人，那么你更有可能表现得好像你真的很害怕亲密感，害怕一段关系可能会付出的代价，这其实一点也不让人意外。很多过度独立的人，一些治疗师称之为创伤反应，但他们甚至可能没有意识到这是一个问题，因为作为一个社会，我们对像独立这样的特质表达了大量的赞许和尊重，
because they resent how closely observed they were. They don't want that to be represented. in their romantic relationships, or perhaps it's this retrospective rebellion or protest against what they found unfair as a child that manifests in them continuing to push people away who want to get close to them in adulthood. Whatever that may be, it obviously differs from person to person, but it can lead to what some researchers call a fear of engulfment, whereby we are afraid of being controlled, dominated, of losing ourselves to a relationship and then being unable to find our way back when the relationship inevitably ends because we have that core attitude that love does not last.
特别是在高度个人主义的西方文化中。独立是非常积极的，它实际上可以表现出在了解自己和自己想要什么方面的很高水平的安全感。但和任何事情一样，我认为平衡是关键。当你的对独立的需要超过了你对连接、社区和亲密感的原始需求时。这就是我们开始看到那些模仿对脆弱感的恐惧、对爱的恐惧或回避型焦虑的模式的时候。我以前其实有一个这样的朋友。而且她曾经是，实际上她现在依然是，我要这么说。我认识的最精彩、最有成就的人之一。
I don't think it's any surprise that if you are an especially hyper independent person, someone who pushes back against requests for assistance, who prefers their own company, who believes in a very deep level that they don't need anyone but themselves. it's obvious that you are more likely to appear as if you are actually afraid of intimacy and you are afraid of what a relationship might cost you. A lot of people who are hyperdependent, some therapists call it a trauma response, but they may not even recognize that this is an issue because as a society, we express a lot of approval and respect for traits like independence,
这个女人跑马拉松。她有自己的生意。她全职读书。她有一百万个爱好。她会烘焙。她会做音乐。她可以教你极其复杂的经济学，甚至连眼睛都不眨一下。她显然，我只是在唱她的赞歌。
especially in highly individualized Western cultures. Independence is incredibly positive and it can actually show a great level of security when it comes to knowing yourself and what you want. But with anything, I think balance is key. And when you need to, your need to be independence outweighs your primal need for connection and for community and for intimacy. That is when we begin to see these patterns that mimic a fear of vulnerability and a fear of love or avoidance anxiety. I used to actually have a friend like this. And she was, actually she continues to be, I will say that. One of the most wonderful and accomplished people I know.
她太棒了。但她对自己的独立性有着极强的保护意识，以至于她拒绝任何试图在非常亲密的层面上了解她的人，因为她确信一段关系会侵蚀她的自由以及她做出最适合自己决定的能力。我老实觉得在某种程度上，这很值得尊敬，她对自己有着高度的奉献精神。老实说，爱不意味着在这些事情上妥协，
This woman runs marathons. She has her own business. She was studying full time. She had a million hobbies. She could bake. She could make music. She could teach you incredibly complicated economics without like even batting an eye. She's obviously, I'm just singing her praises.
但问题是，对的人不会要求你这么做。她认为是在保护自己、把浪漫的爱情拒之门外的做法，实际上成了她最终非常怨恨的事情，而且她无法完全理清头绪，她无法在内心运作的这两种声音之间找到合理的解释，这两种声音非常对立。她想要被爱，但她也想要自由，我想，回顾过去，她无法完全弄清楚这两件事怎么可能是等同的，因为她对爱会对自己做什么有着所有这些消极的信念和看法。我认为这种过度独立、对被吞噬的恐惧、对失去自由的恐惧，是亲密恐惧症的一个我们并没有真正讨论的方面。
She was amazing. But she was so protective of her independence. that she kind of rejected anyone who tried to get to know her on a really intimate level because she was convinced that a relationship would eat into her freedom and her ability to make decisions that were best for her. I honestly think that on some level, there's a lot of respect for that, and she had a great level of dedication to herself. And honestly, love shouldn't mean compromising those things,
过去的恋爱创伤，不仅是在童年时期，也会起到推波助澜的作用。我们经常非常喜欢把童年当作我们依恋创伤的唯一来源，但同样地，我认为许多心理学家、许多研究人员开始意识到，那些青年的恋爱关系、那些初恋、我们早期的爱情经历，当它们变质时，当它们格外困难时，当它们带有创伤性时，它们同样可以塑造我们与人连接的方式。如果你的第一个男朋友或女朋友是一场充满巨大情感和承诺的强烈旋风，然后他们最后出轨了，或者他们最后说了关于你的可怕事情，
but the thing is that the right person won't ask you to. what she thought was protecting her, keeping romantic love at bay, was actually something that she ended up really resenting and she couldn't quite square, she couldn't quite make sense of these two very loud forces operating within her that were very opposed. She wanted to be loved but she also wanted to be free and she couldn't quite figure out, I think, in retrospect, how those two things could be equal because she had all of these negative beliefs and perceptions of what love would do to her. and I think that that hyper independence, that fear of engulfment, that fear of losing freedom, is an aspect of a fear of intimacy that we don't really discuss.
严重损害了你的自尊心，你将很难再去信任或爱别人，即使你拥有非常热情、美好、充满爱意、情感上可用的父母。因为当谈到你对亲密关系的看法时，那仍然是你形成期的一段核心记忆。特别是当我们谈到有人伤害你的自尊心时，那些东西可以持续一生。它会产生不安全感，并产生一种需求，一种保护我们免受未来伤害、免受别人靠得太近、走进我们的生活、对他们产生爱然后又让他们彻底击碎我们的生存本能。
Past relationship trauma, not just in childhood, can also contribute. We often really like to focus on childhood as the only source of our attachment wounds, but equally, I think a lot of psychologists, a lot of researchers are beginning to realize that those teenage relationships, those first relationships, our early experiences with love, When they turn sour, when they are particularly difficult, when they are traumatic, they can equally shape how we connect with people. If your first boyfriend or girlfriend was this like intense whirlwind of huge feelings and commitment, and then they ended up cheating on you, or they ended up saying terrible things about
有时这些经历也确实让我们相信我们不配被爱，任何爱我们的人，我们都欺骗了他们。我们成功地对他们撒了谎。总有一天他们会醒过来，然后他们会像我们过去的那个那样看穿它。他们深深地伤害了我们，以至于每当其他人想要穿过那扇门、想要向我们展示我们错过了什么、向我们展示我们应得的时，我们都会把它视为一种威胁。所以我们推开，我们逃跑，我们不想面对这些想法，不想面对糟糕结果的可能性。所有这一切都会导致一定程度的情感不可用。
you, severely damaging your self-esteem, it is going to be hard for you to trust or love other people, even if you had very welcoming, beautiful, loving, emotionally available parents. because that was still a really formative and core memory for you when it came to your opinions on intimacy. Especially when we talk about someone injuring your self-esteem, that stuff can last a lifetime. It creates insecurity and it creates this need, this survival instinct to protect ourselves from future hurt, from someone else getting too close to us, coming into our lives, feeling love for them and then having them just completely break us down.
我想我们经常通过把人们称为情感不可用（emotionally unavailable）来将他们妖魔化，这完全忽视了前面提到的许多因素和经历。其中很多发生在我们身上，我们并不是确切的参与者。我们被动地接受别人是如何对待我们的，别人是如何教导我们去爱和接受爱的。没有人想觉得自己是不可爱的。没有人想有所保留，但在很多情况下，他们这样做是为了保护自己。而且它通常植根于大量的不安全感、大量的恐惧、以及我们可以真正从中康复的回避模式。不过，如果你没有解决这些问题，如果从来没有人对你说过这些，从来没有人告诉你原来这是这样的，事情就是这样运作的，
And sometimes those experiences also actually convince us that we don't deserve to be loved, that anyone who loves us, we have deceived them. We have lied to them so successfully. And one day they're going to wake up and they're going to see it like that person from our past did. They hurt us so badly that any time someone else wants to come through that door, wants to show us what we're missing, show us what we deserve, we see it, as a threat. So we push away, we run away, we don't want to be confronted by these thoughts, by this potential for a bad outcome. All of this leads to a level of emotional unavailability.
你将继续陷入那些无法满足你的关系中，不断回归现状，对你来说最轻松的事情，那就是独处。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论这带来的某些后果，以及在短短的一秒钟内解构你的亲密恐惧症以及如何克服它。百分之二。那是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《百分之二》中，我剖析了心理韧性、
I think we often villainise people by calling them emotionally unavailable, which completely overlooks so many of the aforementioned factors and experiences. A lot of which happened to us, we're not exactly active in. We're passive to how other people have treated us, how other people have taught us to be loved and to receive love. No one wants to feel unlovable. No one wants to hold back, but they're doing so in a lot of cases to protect themselves. And it's often based in a lot of insecurity, a lot of fear, patterns of avoidance that we can actually recover from. If you haven't worked through these things, though, if no one's ever said this to you, have no one's ever told you that this is how it was, this is how it works,
健身以及在奇异的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油
you're going to continue to end up in those relationships that aren't fulfilling, to keep reverting to the status quo, the easy thing for you, which is to be alone. So we're going to discuss some of the consequences of that after this short break, as well as deconstructing your fear of intimacy and how to move past it in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is a number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。也就是数字“2”%，在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回首过往》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目中，马马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克的日子，但为了让你们都知道。
were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。开始看到其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回首过往》。欢迎来到我的新播客，《艰难求知》，我是你的主持人，你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我在谈。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们在盯着记分牌。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要？你是个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。
I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch.
加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《艰难求知》中就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio App。搜索《艰难求知》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后举行的家庭法院听证会
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你在无声中伪造了这份特定的测试报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed
加入我和我Kear Gaines，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索Learn the Hardway并立即收听。在2023年，前《钻石单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场父子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in silence, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
暴露了她口中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战的序幕，旨在证明真相。你悄悄地篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人遭遇了同样的事情。格雷格，一名女同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉尼尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，来自马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Even though a fear of intimacy is a largely unconscious process, we can still observe how it affects our behavior and our experiences.
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切还远没有结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。尽管对亲密关系的恐惧在很大程度上是一个无意识的过程，但我们仍然可以观察它如何影响我们的行为和体验。
Fear of intimacy is such a struggle. There is so much shame involved, questioning why am I like this? And also a comparison to how everyone else in their 20 years is, you know, looking like they're living their best lives. They're finding partners. They're telling us their love stories. They're getting married. They seem really happy.
对亲密关系的恐惧真是一场挣扎。其中涉及太多的羞耻感，让人质疑为什么我会这样？同时还会与那些二十几岁、你知道的、看起来过着最好生活的所有其他人进行比较。他们找到了伴侣。他们向我们讲述他们的爱情故事。他们结婚了。他们看起来真的很开心。
whilst we stay in this hypervigilant, anxious, avoidance state simultaneously wanting a relationship and petrified of what that might entail, what we could lose, getting hurt again, the courage to put ourselves out there, and just the strength that we might not have at this moment. Some other impacts include, you know, a cycle of emotionally shallow relationships that actually keep reaffirming what we already erroneously believe. which is that love is not fulfilling. It is going to hurt. It will end. It is not worth the commitment.
而我们却停留在这种高度警惕、焦虑、逃避的状态中，既渴望一段关系，又对它可能带来的一切、我们可能会失去的东西、再次受到伤害感到恐惧，同时缺乏展现自我的勇气，以及此刻可能并不具备的力量。其他一些影响包括，你知道的，一种情感上肤浅的关系循环，它实际上不断印证了我们已经错误地相信的事情。那就是爱是无法满足的。它会带来伤害。它会结束。它不值得你做出承诺。
We're actually accidentally creating a self-fulfilling prophecy in those moments because we are pursuing the kinds of relationships that never really challenge us that match what we have come to expect from love. And so we never give ourselves the opportunity to know any differently. The foundations of our fear of intimacy, they remain unchanged, even if it looks like we are putting ourselves out there. even if we're serial dating. A lot of people who I've spoken to who struggle with a fear of intimacy,
在那些时刻，我们其实是在无意中创造了一个自我实现的预言，因为我们追求的是那种永远无法真正挑战我们、符合我们对爱的预期的关系。因此，我们从未给自己机会去了解完全不同的体验。我们对亲密关系恐惧的基础依然没有改变，即使看起来我们正在勇敢展现自我，即使我们一直在频繁约会。许多与我交谈过、正在与对亲密关系的恐惧作斗争的人，
they also talk about a persistent loneliness underneath it all. They do want more. They do want those relationships that are nourishing. But they keep self-isolating or self-sabotaging without even realizing that they're doing it. And they feel like they're doing it all wrong, that they're the ones who make mistakes, that they are just not worthy of love. They were just meant to be alone. I want you to be really gentle with yourself when those thoughts emerge.
他们还会谈到隐藏这一切之下的持久孤独感。他们确实想要更多。他们确实想要那些能够滋养彼此的关系。但他们不断自我隔离或自我破坏，甚至没有意识到自己在这么做。他们觉得自己把一切都搞砸了，觉得自己是那个总是犯错的人，觉得自己根本不配得到爱。他们注定只能孤独一人。当这些想法出现时，我希望你能对自已温柔一点。
You are not alone in this. You are not always going to be alone in this. So many people, people that I know, people I have spoken to, find fulfilling and wonderful and lifelong love out of a place of a fear of intimacy, moving past a place of a fear of intimacy. And it's not a death sentence. It's just something to be aware of, an approach with kindness and forgiveness to yourself. So what can we actually do about addressing our fear of intimacy, both within ourselves and
在这条路上你并不孤单。你不会永远都孤单。有那么多的人，我认识的人，我交谈过的人，他们正是从对亲密关系的恐惧出发，走过了这种恐惧，最终找到了充实、美好且终生的爱。这不是死刑判决。这只是一种需要意识到的状态，一种带着善意和对自己的宽恕去面对的态度。那么，我们究竟能做些什么来解决对亲密关系的恐惧，无论是在我们自己身上，还是
also maybe within the people we're dating? Firstly, you need to do the deep internal work to firstly identify the root of this feeling. We've given kind of a selection of different explanations, but you are the only one who can understand how far back this spans, where this has come from, why this has occurred. I think professional assistants, a therapist during this journey is incredible because they're going to be honest with you. They're going to prompt some of those larger epiphany moments. They're going to bring a neutrality to your situation that will be really helpful. That is going to break yourself shame, Michael, maybe break your pity party, break yourself sabotage.
也许在我们的约会对象身上？首先，你需要进行深刻的内在工作，首先找出这种感觉的根源。我们已经提供了各种不同的解释，但只有你自己才能理解这种情况可以追溯到多远、这一切源自何处、为什么会发生。我认为专业的帮助，比如在这一旅程中寻求治疗师的协助是极其宝贵的，因为他们会对你坦诚相待。他们会促成你的一些重大顿悟时刻。他们会为你的情况带来一种非常有用且客观的视角。这将打破你内心的羞耻感，迈克尔，也许能打破你的自怜，打破你的自我破坏。
I know though that therapy at the moment is quite inaccessible. It's expensive. The waitless are super long. So in the meantime, here are some questions that you can ask yourself to help get to that point of identifying where this feeling may have come from. So the first question I want you to ask yourself is, what is the worst thing that could happen in a relationship? Is it the pain of an ending? Is it the fear that you will lose yourself? That you will have to share parts of yourself that are vulnerable.
不过我也知道，目前的心理治疗相当难以企及。费用高昂。等待名单超级长。所以在等待的同时，这里有一些问题你可以问问自己，帮助你找出这种感觉可能源自何处。所以我想让你问自己的第一个问题是：在一段关系中可能发生的最糟糕的事情是什么？是结束时的痛苦吗？是害怕失去自我吗？是害怕必须分享自己脆弱的那一部分吗？
Why are you so scared of being in love and being seen? what are you actually worried about? Secondly, do you actually feel lovable? And if the answer is no, why is that? Is it because you are nursing a deeper insecurity that is actually the main issue here, but is just manifesting in avoidance? Is it because someone has taught you in the past
为什么你如此害怕恋爱和被人看穿？你到底在担心什么？其次，你真的觉得自己是讨人喜欢的吗？如果答案是否定的，那是为什么呢？是因为你内心怀有一种更深的不安全感，而这才是真正的问题所在，却只是表现为逃避？是因为过去有人教导过你，
that you are unlovable? And you have taken that to be truth. Is it because your parents created an environment where you felt undeserving of attention and care and emotional safety? Once again, this is really revealing. It helps you get to the core of the problem here. Where did this come from? Throughout this process, I think it's also valuable to start breaking down and really examining some of those false beliefs that we all have when it comes to love. Some of those examples, some examples of this include, you know, love is easily broken. It's always going to disappear. If my relationship fails, that's going to prove that I'm unlovable. If I keep my distance, I'm safe and in control. I'm going to be, people are going to be embarrassed of me if they're dating me. People are going to cringe at me. Marriage, relationships, they never work out. They always end. These beliefs all keep
你是不讨人喜欢的？而你却把它当作了真理。是因为你的父母营造了一种环境，让你觉得自己不配得到关注、照顾和情感上的安全感吗？再说一次，这非常有启发性。它能帮你找到问题的核心所在。这一切究竟源自何处？在这个过程中，我认为同样有价值的是开始打破并认真审视我们对爱情所抱有的一些虚假信念。其中的一些例子，这些例子的表现包括，你知道的，爱情很容易破碎。它总是会消失。如果我的关系失败了，那就证明我不讨人喜欢。如果我保持距离，我就是安全的、能掌控一切的。如果别人跟我约会，他们会对我感到尴尬。别人会觉得我很可笑。婚姻、亲密关系，它们从来都不会有好结果。它们总是以结束告终。所有这些信念都让我们
us in a place of fear. And of course, if you've had past experience with her, if your parents got divorced, if you've just had someone treat you really badly, it's not that you've actually, you know, being conscious in accepting those fears and accepting those false beliefs. They've something that you've learned unconsciously and implicitly from your environment. But you need to prove to yourself that they are not the whole truth. And the way we can do that is by visualizing ourselves in a relationship where none of this occurs, when none of this comes true. What would your ideal relationship look like? How would it feel to be loved and cherished? And is that desire bigger than fear for you? Is that something that you really, really want? What activities would you do with your partner? What small ways
困在恐惧之中。当然，如果你过去有过不好的经历，如果你的父母离婚了，如果你只是遇到过对你非常不好的人，这并不是说你真正有意识地去接受了那些恐惧和那些虚假的信念。它们是你从环境中无意识、潜移默化地学到的东西。但你需要向自己证明，它们并不是全部的真相。而我们可以做到这一点的方法，就是在脑海中想象自己身处一段并不会发生这些情况、所有这些都不会成真的关系中。你理想中的关系会是什么样子的？被爱和被珍惜会是一种什么样的感觉？这种渴望对你来说比恐惧更大吗？这是你真正、真正想要的东西吗？你会和你的伴侣做哪些活动？通过什么样的小细节
what they show you love and you show them love in return? How would it feel to say, you know, in five years like, I confronted my fear and I proved it wrong? And now I have this really good thing. And would you be okay if it didn't work out? Yeah, you totally would be. You totally would be. Now, part of this is also about questioning whether this relationship is actually possible. Have you seen an example of this? Or is there a version of this person that you would actually want? Would you be willing to compromise on some of those things that you really, really, really? really think are necessary in a relationship. I'm going to say this again.
他们向你展示爱，而你又如何回报他们？如果能在五年后说出这样的话：“我直面了我的恐惧，并证明它是错的。现在我拥有了这段美好的感情。”这会是什么感觉？如果最后没有成功，你也能接受吗？是的，你完全可以。你完全可以。现在，这其中的一部分还在于质疑这段关系是否真的可行。你见过这样的例子吗？或者说，你所希望的那个人真的存在吗？对于那些你在关系中认为真正、真正、非常必要的条件，你愿意做出妥协吗？我要再说一遍。
You're allowed to want big things for yourself, but don't let that hold you back from a relationship that might not look perfect straight out the gate, but takes time to grow. Like I said before, sometimes we create such impossible standards to actually keep our walls high. This does not mean that you need to settle by no means, but actually that you should examine what conditions for love
你可以为自己树立宏大的目标，但不要让这阻碍你去发展一段一开始看起来或许不那么完美、需要时间去慢慢成长的关系。就像我之前说的，有时我们设定高不可攀的标准，其实只是为了筑高心墙。这绝不意味着你需要将就，而是说你应该审视自己对爱设定了怎样的条件，
you are unfairly imposing as a way to actually protect yourself. This links to my next piece of advice in a way. Be wary of doing a complete 180 when it comes to dating and just artificially accelerating any form of intimacy or connection you have with anyone to just get that label. I think that what we're doing here when we're like, okay, I have a fear of intimacy, I'm just going to get into a relationship and work it all out. What we're doing is putting ourselves through flooding or exposure therapy. So this term flooding is actually something that we borrow from phobia treatment.
而这些条件其实是你为了保护自己而不公平地强加的。这在某种程度上与我的下一个建议有关。在约会时要警惕做出一百八十度的大转弯，不要为了获得一个确定的名分，就人为地加速你与任何人之间的任何形式的亲密感或联系。我认为我们在这里所做的事情，当我们说“好吧，我有对亲密关系的恐惧，我只要进入一段关系并解决它就行了”时。我们所做的一切，其实是让自己经历洪水式疗法或暴露疗法。所以“洪水式疗法”这个术语其实是我们从恐惧症治疗中借用过来的。
When people are scared of snakes or flying or dogs or whatever, clowns, whatever it may be, some therapists engage in this technique where they force us to confront our fears in their most intense and severe form. For example, if you are scared of enclosed spaces, they make you sit in an elevator for hours as a way to bring on panic and then help you work through it. This really helps with objects. The thing is, is that love is not an object or a singular situation. It is so much more nuanced and multi-dimensional than that. But sometimes we try to almost flood ourselves with a really intense relationship to speed up the recovery process and this kind of like DIY healing kind of vibe. Like I'm just going to take the crash course here. I'm just going I put myself on the accelerated path.
当人们害怕蛇、飞行、狗或者其他什么，小丑，无论可能是什么时，一些治疗师会采用这种技术，迫使我们以最强烈、最严重的形式去直面恐惧。例如，如果你害怕密闭空间，他们会让你在电梯里坐上好几个小时，以此引发恐慌，然后帮助你克服它。这对于物体确实很有效。问题在于，爱并不是一个物体或单一的情境。它比这要细致得多，也多维度得多。但有时我们试图通过一段非常剧烈的情感关系来让自己“洪峰过境”，以此加速恢复过程，这有点像那种“DIY治愈”的氛围。就好像我只是要参加这个速成班。我只是
This actually might backfire and it will cause you to just reinforce all the previous ideas that you had about love, that it ends, that it is not good, that it is shallow. It might sound counterintuitive, but I actually think you need to take a break from dating for a while to perhaps interrupt that cycle of emotionally unfulfilling relationships or situations or that pattern of bad dates, that pattern of self-sabotage. You know, sometimes it's important to ask. ask yourself, are you actually just bearing yourself in these temporary feelings in these swipe-based dating apps to ignore what's really going on? Are you trying to expose the fear of
把自己放在了加速的轨道上。这实际上可能会适得其反，并导致你强化先前对爱情的所有看法，比如它会结束、它不是好东西、它是肤浅的。这听起来可能有些违反直觉，但我实际上认为你需要暂时停止约会一段时间，也许是为了打破那种情感上无法满足的关系或情境的循环，或者打破那种糟糕约会的模式、自我破坏的模式。你知道，有时问问自己是很重要的：问问自己，你其实是不是只是把自己埋葬在这些暂时的感觉中、埋葬在这些基于滑动匹配的约会软件中，以此来忽视真正发生的事情？你是在试图将对
intimacy out of you? Flood it out of you or is it something else? I think be wary of going completely in the opposite direction as you move through this journey and instead take six months starting today, maybe, starting tomorrow. Let's say starting tomorrow so you have some time to prepare. Take six months to just really focus on building yourself back up, to regain your confidence, to recognize that you're amazing, to nourish those secret gardens, as we call them, to reconstruct and reform and remold all of those negative, unhelpful attitudes you have about love. There is this amazing resource online. It's called Psych Alive. I will leave a link in the description, but they put it really well. You need to challenge your negative appearance.
亲密感的恐惧从体内排解出去、冲刷出去，还是有别的原因？我认为在这段旅程中，当你要走向截然相反的方向时要保持警惕，相反，不妨从今天开始空出六个月，也许吧，从明天开始。我们从明天开始吧，这样你就有时间做些准备。花六个月时间真正专注于重建自我，重新找回自信，认识到自己的优秀，去滋养那些我们称之为“秘密花园”的地方，去重构、塑造和重塑你对爱情的所有负面、无益的态度。网上有一个很棒的资源。它叫做 Psych Alive。我会在简介中留下链接，但他们说得真的很好。在你真正接纳别人之前，你需要挑战自己对
opinions and attitudes towards yourself before you can really let people in because half the reason we resist connection and love is because we feel undeserving. Or we are terrified that we don't have what it takes to be properly seen and loved and cared for. When you are in a relationship and perhaps you're noticing the urge to push somebody away, that pattern of conflict, of emotional bids, of self-sabotage, overcommunicate as much as you possibly can. Sometimes the only way out is through and what we fear here may be vulnerability, but we kind of have to prove it to ourselves that we can raise our concerns, we can talk about,
自己的负面看法和态度，因为我们抗拒联系和爱，有一半的原因是我们觉得自己不配。或者我们惊恐地发现，自己不具备被人真正看一眼、被爱和被照顾的条件。当你身处一段关系中，也许你注意到自己有一种把别人推开的冲动，那种冲突、情感呼唤、自我破坏的模式，请尽可能多地进行过度沟通。有时唯一的出路就是直面它，我们在这里所害怕的可能是脆弱，但我们某种程度上必须向自己证明，我们可以提出担忧，我们可以谈论
our anxieties and we will receive the reassurance that we need. It's not going to be the end of the world to let someone in. It's actually going to be such a catharsis, such a relief to finally let go of all those things we keep to ourselves, all of those fears, and have someone listen and respond. Now, if someone can't provide you without reassurance and that just like space to listen and understand, it's not you. You are in the wrong relationship and staying until it falls apart may only further entrench the core beliefs that are causing you to run away from love and intimacy. We do see a fear of intimacy being caused by adult relationships. And honestly, you can't risk all the work you're doing towards, you know, deconstructing.
我们的焦虑，并且我们会得到所需的安抚。让一个人走进你的生活并不是世界末日。终于放下所有藏在心底的事情、放下所有的恐惧，并有倾听和回应，这实际上会是一种极大的宣泄和解脱。现在，如果有人无法给你这种安抚、无法提供那种倾听和理解的空间，那不是你的问题。你选错了对象，而死守着一段直到破裂的关系，只会进一步巩固那些导致你逃避爱与亲密感的核心信念。我们确实看到对亲密关系的恐惧是由成年后的关系引起的。老实说，你不能把自己为了消除
your fear of intimacy on someone who might be emotionally unavailable, but not doing what you're doing, which is healing and moving past that, and actually taking the time to really understand the origin, understand how it manifests, understand how it is creating unhealthy patterns or behaviors in you. You know, the chances of that happening of you actually being in a relationship with someone who was emotionally unavailable whilst you were healing a fear of intimacy, it's actually a lot greater than we might expect because we see a lot of people explaining that emotionally unavailable people are more likely to date and be attracted to other emotionally unavailable people because you know that they will never challenge you.
对亲密关系的恐惧而付出的所有努力，全押在一个可能情感上并不可用的人身上。这个人并没有像你一样在疗愈、在超越过去，也没有花时间去真正理解它的起源、理解它是如何表现的、理解它如何在你的身上产生不健康的模式或行为。你知道，这种情况发生的概率——也就是说，当你正在疗愈对亲密关系的恐惧时，你却和某个情感不可用的人在一起——其实比我们预期的要大得多，因为我们看到许多人解释说，情感上不可用的人更有可能与其他人约会并被其他情感上不可用的人吸引，因为你知道他们永远不会挑战你。
So if your partner is the one who exemplifies intimacy avoidance, remember you are an ally in this, but you are not their therapist. You cannot solve their problem for them. I actually think pushing them too hard to do the deep internal work that you might be doing to counteract their negative beliefs and attitudes towards love may actually have the reverse effect you intended and cause them to borrow further into their fear, especially if the root of that fear is a fear of engulfment. I think instead you need a practice staying emotionally present for your own sake and sitting
所以，如果你的伴侣是那个体现出逃避亲密感的人，请记住你是他/她的盟友，但你不是他/她的治疗师。你无法替他们解决问题。事实上，我认为过分逼迫他们去做你可能正在做的深刻内在工作，以对抗他们对爱的负面信念和态度，可能会产生与你预期相反的效果，让他们更深地缩回恐惧之中，尤其是如果这种恐惧的根源是对被吞噬的恐惧。我认为相反，你需要为了你自己的缘故练习保持情感上的在场，去面对
with your own fears and working through them and letting your part. do that work for themselves in parallel. Communicate what you need. Ask them what they need. It's the age old rule of Aloha. Ask, listen, observe, help and ask again. That is all you can do. And when I say help, what I mean is ask them what they need you to do. Is it reasonable? Is it something you can help them with? Can you reassure them? Can you maybe give them some space if that's what they need to just process things but if they're asking you like hey actually i want to break up for like a couple of months because like this is just too much no that is not your job like you are not their sounding board for the
并理清你自己的恐惧，同时让你的伴侣并行地去做他们自己的工作。沟通你的需求。询问他们的需求。这是阿洛哈（Aloha）的古老法则。询问、倾听、观察、帮助并再次询问。这就是你所能做的一切。当我提到“帮助”时，我的意思是问问他们需要你做什么。这合理吗？这是你能帮上忙的吗？你能安抚他们吗？如果这是他们理清思绪所需要的，你能给他们一些空间吗？但如果他们对我说：“嘿，其实我想分手几个月，因为这实在是太多了。”不，那不是你的工作，你不是他们的试验田，
techniques that may or may not work in making them more emotionally unavailable you are not their test dummy pig you are someone who is worthy of love in yourself in in of itself you're worthy of love even if that person isn't able to provide that yet and i think that staying that's in those relationships is actually going to keep you in a version of yourself that you're ready to outgrow. You don't, you know, it's kind of a hard reality is that you can't always bring the person you're with or bring the person you want to take with you on this journey. They might not always be ready or prepared or at the level that you are. And I think that as hard as it might be, sometimes you need to walk away. You cannot heal someone who is not yet at the stage of believing
不是他们用来验证那些可能有用也可能没用的、让他们不再情感冷漠的技术的白老鼠。你是一个本身就值得被爱的人。即使这个人现在还无法提供这种爱，你也值得被爱。我认为，停留在那种关系中，实际上会让你困在那个你已经准备好超越的旧我里。你不会……你知道，一个残酷的现实是，你无法总是带着身边的这个人或你想带的人一起踏上这段旅程。他们可能并不总是准备好、或者没有达到你那样的水平。我认为，尽管这可能很艰难，但有时你需要选择离开。你无法治愈一个还不相信
that anything is wrong. You cannot heal someone who is. You cannot heal someone who is. is not committed to growth the way that you are. And maybe you would be better breaking your own heart, being alone for a while, so that you can find someone who matches where you are at, and who can give you what you need, and who can show you how deserving of love you really are without you needing to beg for it. Don't stay in those situations just because you don't think you deserve better.
有任何问题的人。你无法治愈一个……你无法治愈一个不像你那样致力于成长的人。也许，忍痛割爱、独自独处一段时间会更好，这样你就能找到一个与你处于同一水平的人，一个能给你所需之物、能向你展示你有多么值得被爱而无需乞求的人。不要仅仅因为你觉得自己不配得到更好的，就停留在那种境况中。
Just because someone in your past has taught you these negative false beliefs about your inner worth. You really do owe yourself so much more than that. You really do. You're a wonderful person. You know, the fact that you're listening to this episode shows me that you are committed to actually learning more about yourself. Shows me that you are sensitive, that you are vulnerable with yourself, that you are self-aware. Those are all incredibly positive attributes that you don't want to waste on someone who is emotionally unavailable.
仅仅因为你过去的某个人教导了你关于你内在价值的这些负面虚假信念。你真的值得更好的。你真的值得。你是一个很棒的人。你知道，你能听到这一集，就说明你致力于更多地了解自己。这表明你是敏感的、对自己是脆弱的、是有自我觉察能力的。这些都是极其积极的品质，你可不想把它们浪费在一个情感上并不可用的人身上。
So some final rapid tips here. Process don't avoid the shame or pain. Keep a journal of what you're thinking. Write down those negative false beliefs and those attitudes because I think you might be better able to rationalize them. Take a chance on yourself. You don't need to hide away or disappear. Take risks. Share more.
所以这里有一些最后的快速小建议。去处理而不是回避羞耻或痛苦。写日记记录你的想法。写下那些负面的虚假信念和态度，因为我认为这样能更好地将它们理性化。给自己一个机会。你不需要躲藏或消失。去冒险。多分享。
Invite people in even when it's hard. Slowly accustom yourself to what vulnerability might feel like for you. Put yourself in situations where you are celebrated, not just tolerated. Even if that means leaving friendships that you feel safe in right now because they aren't as emotionally fulfilling. as you deserve. And write down some affirmations about your openness and receptiveness to love and keep them somewhere visible as a reminder. My favorites are pretty simple, but like I'm worthy of love. Love flows effortlessly into my life. Love is joyful. I am enough. I am worthy of a love that reflects my true value. My heart is open to receive love in all of its forms. I know that when
即使在困难的时候也邀请别人走近。慢慢让自己习惯脆弱的感觉。把自己放在一个被庆祝而不仅仅是被容忍的环境中。即使这意味着离开那些你现在觉得安全但实际上在情感上无法满足你的友谊。写下一些关于你对爱的开放和接受态度的肯定语，并把它们放在显眼的地方作为提醒。我最喜欢的非常简单，比如：我值得被爱。爱毫不费力地流入我的生活。爱是充满喜悦的。我已经足够好了。我值得拥有能够反映我真实价值的爱。我的心向各种形式的爱敞开。我知道，当我们
we talk about affirmations, it sounds pretty wishy-washy, but there is really something to be said about creating your reality through the words that you speak to yourself, through the thoughts and cognitions that you have about yourself. If anything, it can't hurt. I think that it's incredibly helpful. I think that it's incredibly powerful to remind yourself without needing that external validation that you are deserving and that there is love coming your way that will make you the most open, honest, vulnerable version of yourself. So I really hope that this episode has been of some help that you've learned a little bit more about where a fear of intimacy comes from, what it creates, the behaviors that are associated with
谈到肯定语时，听起来可能有点空洞或不切实际，但通过你对自己说的话、通过你对自己拥有的想法和认知来创造现实，这确实有其道理。至少，这样做绝对没有坏处。我认为这 incredibly helpful（极其有用）。我认为提醒自己不需要外部验证、自己是值得的、并且将会有爱朝你走来，让你成为最开放、最诚实、最脆弱的自己，这拥有 incredibly powerful（极其强大）的力量。所以我真的希望这一集能对你有所帮助，让你对亲密感恐惧的来源、它所造成的后果、与之相关的行为，
it, but also how to heal the first kind of initial steps to moving forward. You've already there, like you've already recognized this. And if you've recognized it in a partner, have some grace, have a level of forgiveness, but also take care of yourself and realize that it's not you. It really isn't you. This person has probably learned a lot of what they are projecting on you from past relationships, from childhood, and at some point you might need to, like I said, break your own heart for the better, for the better for yourself.
以及如何治愈、如何迈出前行的第一步有了更多的了解。你已经做到了，比如你已经意识到了这一点。如果你在伴侣身上发现了这一点，请给予包容，给予一定程度的宽恕，但同时也要照顾好自己，并意识到这不是你的问题。真的不是你的问题。这个人可能从过去的关系、从童年中，将很多他们投射到你身上的东西学了过来，而在某个时刻，你可能需要像我所说的那样，为了更好的未来忍痛割爱，为了你自己的未来。
So thank you so much for listening. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please make sure that you are following along for future episodes. Make sure you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And if you have someone who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them. Maybe they can take something out of it the way that you have as well.
非常感谢大家的收听。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请确保关注我们以收听未来的节目。请在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你当前收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你身边有人需要听到这一集，请随时分享给他们。也许他们也能从中获得启发，就像你一样。
This episode was actually a suggestion from quite a few listeners. So if you have a suggestion, please feel free to message me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Or you can follow me at Gemma Spegg to see more of what's going on. We will be back on Friday with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
这一集其实是很多听众的建议。所以如果你有什么建议，请随时在 Instagram 上给我发私信，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。你也可以关注我的账号 Gemma Spegg 来了解更多动态。我们将在周五带着新的一集回归。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the Iheart Radio app,
我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即数字 2，百分号，在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾播客》（Look Back at a Podcast）中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。对八四年我很有感触。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。
84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host kids. games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
84 年是个疯狂的年份。我的意思是，那是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人吉姆主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行诚实坦率的对话，这些对话在其他地方真的不太安全进行，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was a cute. accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
让人生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这是一群互联网侦探花了一番功夫才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人遭遇了同样的事情。格雷格，一名女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。